on the side of the people
that flew into the towers
what
do you take away from that day
about the nature about human nature
about good and evil
how did that change your view of the
world
i i i witnessed evil first hand
i remember
later on well into that night when we
were
trying to help get those police officers
out i remember looking up at the
building century 21 the uh store
runs along the uh east side of the
towers and it was still there and you
know the debris had come down right
almost to the edge century 21 is this
old story department store in new york
city
and the sign was was there and it was
still lit up like some of the neon was
broken and but i think some of it was
actually still lit up and i just looked
around and i was like
this is this is a war zone like we're at
war and and you know we knew we were
attacked we heard the fighter planes and
you know back then it wasn't uh the
extensive communication network and we
had cell phones but they were the old
school flip phones and there was no news
on them and so
plus we we didn't have a signal down
there anyway i couldn't reach my family
for like 12 13 hours and
my dad had deployed down to the ferry
terminal to retrieve bodies uh he was
retired but he still went
and they deployed him to go be
basically the morgue transport guys they
expected to be sending
hundreds and thousands of bodies across
on the ferry
and they set up these tractor trailers
as a mobile morgue and uh that never
happened because
there were no bodies to take they were
all buried
um
so i saw evil firsthand i i don't know
how someone can inflict such
ven revenge or or eventual act for in
the name of anything and the name of a
religion and the name of a cause and a
name
like what the hell you know were you
ever able to make sense of that why men
are able to commit such acts of terror
in the days and the years after
no lex i haven't i you know
my mom's from ireland and um i still
have a lot of family there and and you
know my my great uncles
one of them was dragged out and shot no
he lived but but just based on a rumor
that he was in the ira
and i wasn't happy to see what happened
to my mom's people because they they
were
victimized and brutalized by
england at that time
but
blowing up bombs and and killing
innocents in the name of that
it doesn't make it right
i couldn't justify something like that i
i can see
you know i was a cop i was a soldier
and you never want to take life and in
those
jobs but sometimes you have to
but you don't do it with a vengeance you
don't do it with a thirst you do it
because it's necessary for survival
when you do it out of a bloodlust out of
a thirst out of a cause
that's evil there's something wrong with
you
i i have no
i i respect life to the highest level i
i mean i'm very life is sacred to me
it's precious it's beyond
it's not a commodity it's a gift
but to take life just so randomly so
there's something way wrong with that
person and and maybe i'm a conflicted
soul
but i would have no problem seeing
someone like that put to death because
they do not deserve life
there's there's many uh
many children around this world that are
being taught to hate
someone who's different than them
just because the the person who's
allegedly teaching them says so
i don't understand well that starts with
just having a basic um
respect and appreciation for the other
human beings
you